herr bürgermeister danke dass wir da
sein dürfen wir mit ihnen reden hallo
was die vielen dank wie würden sie denn
jemanden der kev noch nie gesehen hat
noch nie hier war ihre stadt aktuell
beschreiben ich bin die ehemalige stadt
habe keine explosion gemacht meine
allererste job habe
dubai gewesen meine stadt und
liebigstraße sehr gerne geschichte vom
mann str und ich möchte sagen dass es
die stadt hat sehr viel ähnlichkeit mit
hamburg die einige fluss in die
stadtmitte eine steuer nächste urteile
vom status fühlen und andere teile flach
und gibt es sehr viele inseln und so
ähnlich mit mariani wollen die stadt ist
sehr sehr gut
riesige fluss ich habe gesagt und
gastfreundliche menschen leben in
unserer stadt und deswegen mir das eine
echte europäische stadt
genieße werde
kommen nach vorn ausland mit anzutragen
die wilde osten um danach die sehen dass
die stadt ist echt schon das ist richtig
europäische stadt und meine aufgabe
alles
auch manager von der stadt das richtige
label sturm party machen wie in europa
europäische müssten warten jetzt erlebt
man aktuell tagsüber die cafés sind voll
viele menschen sind auch draußen es ist
schönes wetter dann gibt es aber immer
wieder auch alarmsirenen wie erleben sie
die menschen in ihrer stadt ganz aktuell
jetzt im moment noch vor paar monate die
stadt war ganz leer und
siehst du keine keine autos keine
fußgänger jetzt im moment gewollte
kommen wieder schon zu hause ist immer
besser kann man schon wieder und man
hört dass er nicht so oft und leider oft
geräte haben wir noch nicht nur letzte
woche
führung
verketten in unsere richtung unserer
stadt geflogen 4 ist in unserer stadt
wandern viele gebäude zerstört ich
möchte noch dazu sagen seit kans bank
mehr als 300 gebäude
renoviert
220 wohngebiete wohngebäude das
mitmenschen
120 menschen sind gestorben 16 kinder
wir sind verletzt stark verletzt der und
schwer verletzt und vier davon gestorben
das es nur in unsere stadt
das krieg hat unsere stadt tief
getroffen und menschen hat wohl gelernt
unter der erde verbracht weil er
ununterbrochen haben wir dieses rennen
gehört so das bedeutet dass seine zeit
man muss schnell wie möglich in eine
dunkle zu kommen weil das war viel zu
gefährlich
mittlerweile geht die sirene los und die
leute machen aber gar nichts sie machen
einfach weiter
die schon gewohnt das ist die serie ist
ungebrochen
gehört weil er ja das ist die
menschen daran geworden und die solche
gefährliche vision geben befürchten sie
denn dass es einen neuen massiven
angriff der russischen armee auch auf pf
geben wird ich weiß es
überhaupt ziehen und bleibt noch
hauptziel von russische adresse das ist
hauptstadt das des herzens der landes
deswegen deswegen wir arbeiten sehr
viele und
mit zu wenig beteiligung war aber das
betrifft neuer zustand neue realität wo
leben wir
und sehr viele herausforderungen der
mieter habe ich denn jetzt der
bundeskanzler nach kiew kommt werden sie
ihm auch ihre stadt ein bisschen zeigen
können ich genieße mein start zusage und
genieße die zu präsentieren wie schon
eine stadt wie gute start das ist eine
echte europäische staat und hamburg eine
gelegenheit für
bundesheer mainstraße präsentieren ich
werde mich überhaupt nicht wie vor ist
das schon fest oder ist es noch in der
planung oder gibt es noch gar kein
termin ist das war es jetzt eine solche
bedingung für eine feste planung man
kann nicht mal es gibt viele menschen
die wir getroffen haben hier in kiew in
der ukraine aber auch viele menschen in
deutschland die sich fragen wie und wann
wird das alles enden haben sie da eine
idee
schwierig zu sagen ich weiß es wie kann
man recht wie gewinnen dieses gerät
diese sinnlose krieg ich habe keine
zweifel
weil jedoch eine sehr motiviert wie
beteiligen die
situationisten fragen wieso sie sind so
sicher ich möchte eine sache wie die
sirene das in jedem krieg das geht um
menschliche leben
viele worte sind schon gestorben und die
ganze welt ist bewundert wie auch eine
sciaroni steht gegenüber die die
stärksten in der welt russische armee
und so
man kann so sagen erfolgreich beteiligt
und so das land ich möchte einfach dass
das einfach zu beschreiben das russische
soldaten kämpfen für das geld gut
bezahlt und unsere soldaten riesenrad
riesige motivation wir verteidigen
unsere hand wie vielseitig unsere städte
wie verteidigung unserer familie und
unsere kinder
die gesetze seien zu sterben
für das geld oder zu sterben zu seiner
kinder und wir sind fest überzeugt
wir werden niemals wie haben keine
solche gedanken wie wir werden nie
aufgeben wir werden weiter kämpfen um
zwei dingen unsere familie unsere kinder
unsere zukunft aber es kostet sehr sehr
viel auch menschenleben auch ukrainische
menschenleben gerade jetzt im moment
aktuell sehr hohe verluste
wie gehörverlust er wir haben keine
andere wollen wir haben keine andere
wahl und
auf gewinnen das ist keine option für
uns rainer war immer eine friedliche
land wo er leben friedliche menschen wir
waren niemals aggressiv gegen andere
länder und was jetzt passiert dass es
eine
russland hat die alle werte gebrochen
alle regeln gebrochen
das ist
was hierzu moment passiert das ist eine
dreijährige tier nicht für hochreine das
tragödie für ganz
europa für ganze kontinent und auch ich
noch dazu sagen das ist eine riesige
tragödie fuß und die begleitung noch
nicht aber das ist auch da geht er für
russland dass es die us soldaten sterben
auch das ist eine tragödie für millionen
von menschen in europa wie muss nicht
vergessen dass es die größte
krieg nach der zweite weltkrieg in
europa und wenn hier man denkt das ist
dieser krieg betrifft ihn persönlich
nicht wenn jemand denkt täglich ist weit
weg das ist eine falsche aufstellung
diese krieg kann jeden treffen jede in
europa
ich noch eine sache das ist
keine nur 450 erste station
und eine davon war
in frontlinie das war ein die in ihm
vorher und werden eine explosion wird
dass es wird sich miley große
diskussionen alles
tschernobyl-katastrophe das kann jeden
treffen wenn der krieg jetzt noch sehr
lange weitergeht ist ja zu befürchten
dass auch das interesse der menschen in
der welt nachlässt weniger wird und
damit auch der druck auf die politik wie
sehen sie das
wir sind so etwas wie ihr da muss jeder
muss gestehen die sieben von diese
sinnlose krieg
das ist ich möchte extra erklären für
jeden für jeden wird gesteht dass nicht
die sinne und diese sinnlose krieg auch
eine wieder zurück in russische india zu
bringen
diesen ist eine unserer wunsch ein teil
von europäische familie zu sein weil wir
sind dran angeles entschieden
europäische werte hat eine wichtigste
priorität für unseres land virus unter
zitiert nicht die wollen wiederum
schönberger aufzubauen und wir sprechen
schon optimal baltische lernte und wie
muss man auch nicht vergessen der
tschechoslowakei hungern und auch ball
und und auch großer teil eine große
teile hindurch und war auch ein teil von
seelische in berlin und wir wissen nicht
wie weit die pläne von adressen ich habe
gedacht dass es die wird zufrieden mit
kremation
dies nicht zufrieden die wollen des
logos die wollen wir wollen nicolai sie
wurden nach dessen bewohner tief das ist
die interessen geht wahrscheinlich bis
zum polnischen grenze vielleicht noch
weiter bis zum 3 vielleicht noch weiter
bis zum deutschland
die menschen in deutschland kennen sie
ja jetzt schon länger wie hat der krieg
sie verändert ganz persönlich diese
diese sinnlose krieg hat
lebens verändert in millionen von
menschen
flüchtlinge
die 1000 1000 den menschen
[Musik]
schon gestorben das ist eine riesige
tragödie und und für sie könnten
persönlich was merken sie an sich selbst
das ist ein mehr als 100 tage krieg
dauert für mich persönlich dass er seine
lern gelder langer tag das ist nonstop
die herausforderung wir mussten menschen
helfen will muss ein menschenleben
retten die mussten
in krankenhäuser menschen bringen wir
müssen helfen mit mit service mit
erwärmung mit wasser das ist dass es
eine riesige herausforderung weil der
die wirtschaft gespräche als wo meine
arbeit perspektive als bürgermeister von
kapstadt dass es ich bin zuständig für
service lieferung an meine bürger von
eine seite von einem von anderer seite
privates leben habe ich nicht ich hoffe
irgendwann hab ich zeit
bis hin zu schaffen dass es nonstop das
ist jede sekunde musste einsatzbereit
sein und
in menschen zu helfen
das leben hat die persönliche mischung
von vielen menschen der teils ändert und
wie sehen die wurde sehen seine familie
wurde hat pläne für jetzt.de usd ab groß
geworden und
ist eine riesige tragödie bekommt man
kitsch vielen dank
nicht sogar danke für unterstützung
danke für jede wehr kf miet und muss man
sie nicht vergessen diese sinnlose krieg
an ihre verstehen um eine anstellung die
creek ist weit weg und berührt mich
nicht dass es eine große fehler wir
müssen alles machen
alles proaktiv so sein in diesen krieg
zu stoppen vielen dank